for first place all the marbles and so
many points of the GCT somebody's
walking away with 13 GCT points what a
oh he missed it he missed an opportunity
for Rook A3 was that just a pin and you
win the the bishop you you oh you would
win an exchange that would have been an
easy dra E4 is in trouble he has to play
five this is no longer a draw oh four
against nine by the way this will be
decided on on on oh did he W oh my God
Wasa he played rookie 2 and lost The
Rook oh this is a draw now yes Fabby
will be our oh my goodness and Fabiano
Carana is the winner of the St Louis
rapid and Blitz dram drama to the last
drop congratulations to Fabby but yeah
that was quite something and there he is
13 GC points in his pocket so impressive
the way he made his comeback from the
rapid